Do you know that bees are talking to each other outside?
Bees swing and dance to share information about the location
Distance to nearby attractions. Suppose you are trapped in a beehive, and
The friendly and busy bees in your hive go out for food. On her journey she found a flower
Powdered pollen. She turned back to tell you where the rest of the hive is.
How to tell? Distance and direction, my friend.
She wobbled and swayed when she walked in. It was really fast.
This line. When she reached the end, she turned to the left and returned to the circle
The beginning. I wobbled again, now I turn to the right, back to the beginning, swing again, turn around
Go to the left... Did you know? Are we really? Need to mix like the entire electronic bee dance?
What's really cool is that its length varies from swing to swing.
This way is completely related to the distance traveled by the bees. The closer the destination, the shorter the swing.
In fact, every second has a wave of running, the bee tells you to travel 1 km. and so,
What, we have kilometers, miles, and bees have rickety swings?
Ok, 1 km, ready! But where are you going? Like a compass, up is a comparison of bees
Reference, that is, the sun. Upward means toward the sun. The angle of the swing operation tells us
On the way, you can keep the sun above you. Combine this angle with your distance,
You are ready now! Other information may actually be hidden here
"Shake the 'rotate' routine, just like familiar: experienced bees may pay special attention
The dancers who came to the smell of familiar flowers came down
Or maybe it’s dangerous, the dancers are hovering around the destination, doing less swing around
It is a dangerous goal. If we compare other bees in other parts
In the world, we even found the possibility of swinging dialects and social learning.
The bee can accept a lot of things. Click on the buzz to talk about animal communication, and
Don't forget to subscribe to the language!